we got a question right here from a
fellow that sent this in right here and
obviously a joe burrow fan r.i.p
morgan this is flim from washington dc
yes phlegm like the [ __ ] in your throat
by way of alabama and this question for
both you guys i just wanted to know
uh when you guys were up and coming and
making your way whether it's in stand-up
or
in country music did you ever book a gig
or show up to a venue and there was only
like
two or three people there and since you
had already booked they were being paid
you just had to power through
and uh how awkward was that for you
thanks
gang gang hey bro that's a good question
man yeah phlegm that's a
hey in honor of him and on her burrow's
leg
clear my throat right there i can't get
a boy oh
good question um i did i did did you
yeah bro i did a few of those yeah
um
just one i wish there was only one i
know
um probably my most notable one
was like i don't even know if i'd gotten
a record deal yet
it was right when i first moved to to
nashville and my booking agent was like
because i had a band you know and he was
like well i wanna we're gonna i'm gonna
send you out on the road and play some
cover band shows and just make sure just
get you guys in your band just a little
tighter and you know make sure you guys
are good right
excuse me all right cool whatever what
was the band's name
oh it was just me oh it's still yeah you
and your baby okay got it go
sorry but we were singing like like we
were playing like a long long sets you
know like
a couple three hours like a long time
right you're doing weddings
yeah basically yeah yeah yeah except i
think weddings paid a lot better
um and you know there would have
probably been some hot girls
this was not that a lot of stuff that
oh yeah just just got off the public
golf course
a lot of rosy cheeked old men huh yeah
santa's little helper
and uh probably this one man it was in
greenville north carolina
it was the first one we had done man and
i but so the what they told us was we're
going to go to green north carolina
that's where east east carolina
university is like okay cool you know
it's like a it's like a friday or
something yeah yeah there's sure
there'll be a lot of
there's some yeah the pirates yeah
there'll be some there'll be a lot of
college kids out here you know hell yeah
this would be great let me get there and
like the first thing that dude says to
us he's like yeah by the way guys
it's rush week or something none of the
fractious reuters is allowed to go out
that's bad okay
great no idiot you know maybe there's
some people that stuck around this town
that are a little
a little younger there's some people
that dropped out of school
they didn't make to the front you know
[Laughter]
we go up there and i saw him as soon as
he starts saying that i start pounding
pbrs
just in the middle of the day i'm like
oh this is gonna be
oh yeah this is gonna be bad that's the
north carolina state bird the pbr dog
man
but uh man we get out there and i'm i'm
pretty lit dude and like honestly
we have not had a chance to practice
that much and there's a bunch there's a
bunch of songs on this list you know
so i'm down there making up words with
these songs lit singing and there's like
four people you know one person
kind of dancing a little bit by himself
yeah i couldn't tell you who was
actually there
but uh i start midway like do it i'm
like halfway talking [ __ ] to the to the
crowd i'm like god you gotta suck
i'm just not not having enough time i'm
not feeling at all making you know
telling my band to replay the chorus and
that then you know let's do that
let's just keep the song going because i
don't know the next yeah yeah and it was
like one of those
moments where i knew i didn't want to do
that i didn't want to play cover band
shows yeah
because it was extremely difficult and
you just don't even know what you're
going to get so that i think that that
moment
i'm pretty sure one of my buddies that i
brought with me like told the guy his
bar sucked and like
he got kicked out of the bar like
you know one of the five people there
was my buddy and he got kicked out
because he was being an idiot
and it just but it was one of those
moments i was like well i need to get it
together we really need to
we got i want to make something of this
i really really love singing i really
don't like
singing other people's music the whole
time i'd really like to see my own yeah
so let's
let's hone in and and really work on
this and that was like that was the
worst one we ever the first one was the
worst one i mean
we kept getting better damn and you're
still with some of the same guys today
yeah
everybody in that band is still in my
vein except for my or one of my guitar
players and it was not any bad blood or
anything he he just got married and
wanted to stay at home
oh yeah i heard about that i remember
you talked about that in a different
interview
yeah man that's wild dude i remember
let me think i remember
one time uh they brought me out it was a
this was actually a greek event this was
in this is like university of north
florida or something
so they bring me out i don't know
it's one of those schools you're like i
don't know if this really is school
there's like 18 schools in florida and
that ain't that's yeah yeah they cut it
off
that's number 19. there's like four gyms
on campus you're like this [ __ ] is a
little weird you know
i guess it ain't this ain't checking out
so they're like okay we need you to go
out there start the show off it's gonna
be great right i go out there but these
kids do not give a [ __ ]
about me all they care about is seeing
their friends who are performing because
each one of the greek groups has like
one of they're doing something
they're doing like a uh you know they're
playing a song or doing a skit okay so i
got a talent show
yeah talent show so i go out there and i
guess they didn't consider me talent
so i go out there bro they're they're
booing so i'm
just ripping through my material because
that's all i have is my only weapon yeah
my only weapon is just these words that
i have you know
and only have about 15 minutes of
material so i burned through that in
about seven minutes oh yeah
you know uh yeah because part of your
thing is like pausing and
yeah yeah totally none of that bro every
time i pause i can feel how much more
they hate me
you know somebody these pauses are
pretty painful
so i get through that i bring out the
group who's performing coming out next
and i get backstage and like that was
good
uh and they're like you're back up in
three minutes or something right and i
had to go out seven more times out onto
that stage you had no mormons here for
15 minutes each
uh no no for like three minutes each
after that you're like the host kind of
yeah
man it got so bad bro like the third
time
dude the third time i picked up an
american flag that was backstage and
just walked out with
just that was it some somebody singing
national anthem out here yeah totally
like i was surrendering i just was
giving up
spray paint that thing white it was bad
just going over the red yeah yeah dude
it was bad man but by the end it was
almost funny that i kept coming out
there like no way he's coming back out
and i'd be like i'm back
how long ago was that man that was
probably 10
years ago but one the one that hurt my
feelings most i had a special that came
out on netflix probably a few years back
about five years ago
and i thought man this is it i made it
i've watched it
thanks man i appreciate that yeah yeah
uh and so
i get out there i go to chattanooga in
chattanooga i'm performing
and i'm excited i get there i'm thinking
it's going to be hype dude finally
people are coming i've been doing this
for you know
nine years 10 years finally people are
gonna come out
and i got there bruh and there's like
seven people there
oh it didn't do anything dude and there
was just
one like and one one girl came bro
and that's always it hurts you because
it makes you think like
dang dude i wish it wasn't her who came
but also
we'll see how it goes you know this is
only one girl
bro she was she was a tough girl boy
she had all the shoulders brushed she
was just a strong lady
you know yeah you met her no i've met a
few yeah okay
yeah i mean we i love linebackers too
you know yeah no she was uh
yeah she was she was just and i still i
think i did actually end up making out
with her honestly
yeah you know she came you gotta
you appreciate her you know oh dude and
she's a great girl she's a very sweet
girl
and actually enough years later she came
up to me said do you remember me
and i said i before the show i don't i
don't think so you know she said i came
to your show in chattanooga
and i was like man and i was actually
pretty grateful she considered she was
one ninth of the audience you know yeah
yeah
i'm here yeah she was at least a night
you know
but it was uh yeah that was a tough one
man
so you you were having this that was nev
that was when they filmed the netflix
thing that's when it no that's when it
came out on there oh got you so i
thought that
well i'm on netflix i'm yeah i made it
yeah and damn it didn't do it didn't do
anything
it's it's i mean that's that is a that's
an interesting thing you know you get or
like
for me it'd be like spotify or something
you know like all right i got on i got a
hot country sure
now i've made it people people are gonna
care now just because some just because
the editor
really cares about me means everyone in
the world is going to care you know
it's not always how it goes you know you
and it's interesting to think
you they just got to care about you not
because not because
netflix does or because hbo does or put
you know those those people are just
taking risks it's not like
they're not god telling these people to
to watch you know
right sometimes we give them that power
i think i always did especially when i
was coming up i gave
the media that power well i think the
media probably had a little bit more
power when you were coming up yeah
because they didn't or even maybe a
little further than that
because that was a lot of people's only
way of of getting to see you
right there wasn't as much social media
there wasn't as much youtube it was like
yeah they were really watching yeah yeah
yeah now it's like somebody offered a tv
show i said
i've turned down television shows left
and right it's just like i wouldn't i
would just have more success because i
found success eventually by just
starting my own thing
yeah you know and going and doing things
like joe rogan like guys like that like
saying come on the podcast and then
that's what changed
me at least people being able to at
least see me for me
you know but like you're saying more of
a natural thing they they gravitate
towards you
it's something about like they can push
it as many times you can push the spins
as many times they want but if there's
not something
i think that they if there's not
something deeper in there then it's not
going to stick
it won't man and it's interesting and
like for for i mean i don't know what it
i don't it's hard to put that into words
too it's like i don't know what
what it is that people like about me or
what it is that people like about you
but clearly there's something that they
are drawn to
to that they feel connected to that i
think it's just being real dude
yeah i really do a lot of people just
think they have to be a certain way or
do a certain thing like oh i'm a country
music singer i gotta
huh you know
i need a cowboy hat now you know it's
like it's not you know i don't know they
i think they just really know
they can everybody has a really good way
of sensing out
uh someone who's not who's not being
genuine yeah
yeah i think authenticity is definitely
becoming more and more of a uh
commodity than it used to be but you
also have to be cool you have to be
your authentic self needs to be cool you
know like if you're if you're not then i
guess you're just out of luck
you know like if you're just not a cool
person then yeah you're like damn
larry's authentic is [ __ ] about he is
lucky
exactly so it's kind of if you don't if
you don't have both
yeah you gotta have a certain amount of
authenticity good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah